you don't need luck to be a successful
screenwriter aren't there people that
look into it or it just seems that way
I'm one of those people who believes in
you create your own luck is luck a
factor any you know in anything the
stars sometimes have to come into
alignment before something becomes
possible but the thing about luck is you
have to be ready for it when it arrives
and that is where craft comes in yes I
remember I'm not I just I got just plain
lucky several times along the way but
then I had a closet full of work that I
could that I could use and prove and and
verify that I was really good at this
and that I was the one worth taking a
shot with it's not just luck you can't
blame it on luck if you're not making
headway you takes a lot of time and you
have to be improving your craft forever
the thing about screenwriting is truly
then and the best ones will say this
I've heard it from the best ones you
never master this craft never it's too
intricate
but if you master your tools you can you
can continue to have pleasure in it live
in it live the lives I've lived hundreds
of lives you know it's just it's it's a
very rewarding thing to do even when
it's rough you know even when even when
you're not selling but it's as well
worth doing and
when luck comes and if you're around
long enough if you're at it long enough
opportunity will come but you must be
ready to make the maximum of that
opportunity
no no deer-in-the-headlight time you
know when the headlight hits
you are ready to tap-dance and you've
got your scripts you have studied
pitching you know how to pitch that is
we haven't really gone into that but
that is really key to this business and
there's no way around it yeah yeah I
reckon I recommend my different Michael
Higgs book what is it selling your story
in 60 seconds I think is approximately
his title you got to know this stuff and
I don't care if you're shy you know you
can still learn to pitch a 60 120 second
story tell your story and there's a
there's this thing a story an old story
that goes around that when when we're
practicing working on pitching in
courses and stuff and people sometimes
having fun so other people are upset by
it and and I say just just be as nervous
as you want to be it's not about
pitching is not about not being nervous
it's really not said once upon a time
there was this creative executive that
worked for a very very powerful producer
and he comes bursting into the producers
office one day and he says Alice I just
heard the most dynamic story I have
heard in five years it's perfect there's
a star as a role for a star it's funny
it's touching it's just the best story
I've heard for ages but I had to I had
to pass because the the writer was
nervous they don't give a damn if you
were halting or if you are nervous they
don't give a damn if you have trouble
pitching and that you know you're doing
something that everything in you wants
to resist tell them your story whoever
you are
there is room in this business for
everybody tell them your story be
nervous as you want to be they are in
the story business if your story is
ready if you've checked away and shaped
it into a into a pitiable form really a
powerful story and if your timing you
luck in timing if your timing is right
don't worry about it it'll all take care
of itself
you